LUIS, MARK, DAN.
FANTASTIC.
>> YOU HAVE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE COMING FROM
GUATEMALA, FROM HONDURAS AND
EL SALVADOR.
AND THEY MARCH UP THROUGH
MEXICO.
BY THE WAY, IF WE DIDN'T HAVE
WALLS IN THOSE AREAS, IN SOME
CASES THAT WE PUT UP IN MANY
CASES WHERE WE REINFORCED, IN
MANY CASES WHERE OUR GREAT
MILITARY HELPED US WITH BARBED
WIRE, YOU WOULD HAVE PEOPLE
POURING IN.
THEY DON'T POUR IN.
>> Laura: THAT WAS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE OTHER NIGHT
SPELLING OUT THE DANGERS THAT
ARE INVOLVED INSIDE THESE
CARAVANS.
THAT MAKE THEIR WAY FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA THROUGH MEXICO
TO OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
TONIGHT IN A "THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE" EXCLUSIVE, WE
HAVE WORD THAT YET ANOTHER
CARAVAN IS FORMING.
ONE THAT OUR NEXT GUEST SAYS
COULD BE THE BIGGEST YET.
RUNNING IS NOW EXQUISITELY,
GUATEMALAN SECRETARY OF
INTELLIGENCE MARIO SORT US.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON.
WHAT DO WE NEED TO KNOW?
YOU HAVE BEEN WARNING ABOUT THIS
FOR YEARS ACTUALLY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK ABOUT
CENTRAL AMERICA, I'VE BEEN THERE
A LOT, AS YOU KNOW.
SPENT A LOT OF TIME IN
EL SALVADOR AND GUATEMALA.
WHY CAN'T WE GET MORE HELP FROM
OUR FRIENDS IN GUATEMALA OR
EL SALVADOR OR HONDURAS?
WHY ALLOWING PEOPLE FROM
HONDURAS, YOU ARE LETTING THEM
THROUGH AND THEY ARE MAKING
THEIR WAY TO MEXICO, WHY?
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME,
LAURA.
I THINK IT'S NOT COMPLETELY
CORRECT TO SAY THAT WE ARE JUST
ALLOWING THEM THROUGH.
GUATEMALA SIGNED WITH DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES OF CENTRAL AMERICA, A
TREATY THAT ALLOWS
CENTRAL AMERICAN CITIZENS TO
FLOW FREELY THROUGH
CENTRAL AMERICAN TERRITORY.
HOWEVER, WE HAVE BEEN UNDER THE
CONDITION THAT --
>> Laura: THERE IS THE
GUATEMALA-MEXICO BORDER.
>> THEY REPORT AT THE BORDER.
THIS IS A DIFFERENT SITUATION.
WHAT HAPPENED, A VIOLENT
OVERPOWERING OF OUR POLICE
FORCES AND OF OUR BORDER.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE ORGANIZERS OF
THIS CARAVAN PUT LITTLE KIDS,
BABIES, WOMEN AND THE ELDERLY AT
THE FRONT AND STARTED PUSHING
THEM AGAINST THE POLICE FORCES.
WE NEED TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
HUMAN RIGHTS, OF THEIR DIGNITY,
OF THEIR LIVES.
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE HAD TO -- THE
LIVES OF THOSE PEOPLE, THOSE
INNOCENTS, OR ALLOWING THEM INTO
OUR TERRITORY.
WE DID AND EFFORT AND PRESIDENT
MORE OR LESS ORDERED SECURITY
FORCES TO SET UP DIFFERENT
CHECKPOINTS.
WE ENDED UP RETURNING MORE THAN
6,500 HUNDREDS BACK TO HONDURAS
THAT WERE ILLEGALLY IN GUATEMALA
IN THESE CARAVANS.
>> Laura: YOU ARRESTED
HUNDREDS ISA SUSPECTS.
THEY WERE NOT PART OF THAT
CARAVAN.
IT WAS ERRONEOUSLY REPORTED THAT
THEY WERE ARRESTED IN GUATEMALA?
>> THESE ARE SPECIAL-INTEREST
ALIENS.
>> Laura: IT'S REPORTED AS
ISIS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE FROM
COUNTRIES --
>> SUSPICIOUS ALIENS, SOME WITH
POSSIBLE LINKS.
TERRORIST ORGANIZATIONS.
>> Laura: THAT'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN GUATEMALA THAT YOU
SENT.
IS THERE A CONCERN AT ALL THAT
THROUGH THE CARAVAN OTHER PEOPLE
CAN SLIP IN?
WE KNOW MS-13 HAS SLIPPED INTO
THE CARAVAN, AND MANY CARTEL
FORCES HAVE MADE THEIR WAY INTO
CARAVANS IN MEXICO BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE THE REPORTS ARE.
>> THOSE ARE PARTS OF THE
THREATS AND RISKS THAT COME WITH
THE CARAVANS.
THINK ABOUT MS-13, THEY HAVE
BEEN WEAPONIZE.
THESE INNOCENTS HAVE BEEN
WEAPONIZED AS POLITICAL TOOLS OF
THE SOCIALIST MOVEMENT
THROUGHOUT LATIN AMERICA.
>> Laura: POLITICAL ACTIVISTS
ARE PUSHING THESE CARAVANS?
>> RIGHT.
>> Laura: THIS GROUP, PUEBLO
SIN FRONTERAS IN THE
UNITED STATES, THEY HAVE ONE
LEAD ORGANIZER, HE'S AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S A PROBLEM AND
HE'S BEEN, I BELIEVE HE WAS
ARRESTED DOWN THERE IN MEXICO
AND THEY ARE PART OF THE
COACHING SQUAD TO COACH
EVERYBODY TO SAY THEY HAVE A
CREDIBLE FEAR.
WHY IS CENTRAL AMERICA BEING
DEPOPULATED?
>> IT'S NOT SO MUCH DEPOPULATED.
LIKE I SAID, THESE LEFTIST
ACTIVISTS WITH THE PURPOSE OF
UNDERMINING CONSERVATIVE
MOVEMENTS IN THE UNITED STATES
AND IN OUR COUNTRIES, ARE
WEAPONIZING THESE PEOPLE IN
NEED, OFFERING THEM A FALSE
OPPORTUNITY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY ARE FALLING FOR IT.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THIS
OTHER CARAVAN?
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> IT'S MISSING.
IT'S COMING THROUGH THE
COLOMBIAN JUNGLE INTO PANAMA.
>> Laura: COLOMBIAN JUNGLE?
IT'S COMING FROM SOUTH AMERICA?
>> SOUTH AMERICA TO --
>> Laura: ANY VENEZUELANS
HOOKING IN WITH THIS CARAVAN?
>> SOME.
MOSTLY CUBANS AND AFRICANS.
>> Laura: 30,000 STRONG?
>> THAT'S THEIR PURPOSE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE THEY WANT TO PUT
TOGETHER.
AGAIN, IT'S ANOTHER CARAVAN
FORMING WITH THE SAME INTENT,
BEING COACHED BY PEOPLE, BEING
WEAPONIZE, LIKE I SAID, BY THE
LEFTIST MOVEMENTS.
>> Laura: THIS IS AN AMERICAN
COMMENTATOR.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAYS ABOUT OUR
WALL AND WHETHER THERE'S ANY
CRISIS.
LET'S WATCH.
>> HISTORY WILL REALLY FROWN ON
THE REPUBLICANS.
YOU GAVE ONE INSTANCE.
HOW ABOUT SENDING TROOPS DOWN
WHEN THERE'S NO CARAVAN COMING?
SENDING AMERICAN TROOPS DOWN
LITERALLY LIKE TINKER TOY
SOLDIERS, AND WE CAN GO ON AND
ON AND ON, AND A STANDBY INTO
ME, YOU KNOW, YOU SEE WHAT YOU
WHAT YOU GET WITH TRUMP.
>> Laura: OKAY, SO HE WAS
TALKING WITH THE CARAVAN, NOT
THE WALL.
NO CARAVAN.
THERE ARE NO CARAVANS?
>> PROBABLY THEY ARE WATCHING
THE WRONG CHANNEL.
YOU NEED TO WATCH FOX NEWS MORE.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
THERE'S NO CARAVANS.
NO CRISIS.
DO YOU SEE IT AS A CRISIS IN
GUATEMALA WITH PEOPLE COMING
THROUGH?
>> IT DEFINITELY WAS A CRISIS
FOR US.
WE HAD TO DEPLOY OVER 3,000
STRONG POLICE OFFICERS,
MILITARY, EMTs,
FIRST RESPONDERS THROUGHOUT THE
BORDERS TRYING TO STOP THE
ILLEGAL FLOW OF MIGRANTS.
WE HAD TO CHECK ON THEM AND MAKE
SURE --
>> Laura: WE ARE GOING TO KEEP
CHECKING WITH YOU, BUT WE'VE GOT
TO WORK TOGETHER, OUR COUNTRIES,